[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
27 years later the case that shocked the
nation all of the evidence
points to o.j simpson but not everyone's
convinced the jews killed his ex-wife
and her friend just believed in my heart
of hearts
that simpson absolutely 100 percent was
not guilty
and closing arguments in the tennessee
trial of a father accused of murdering
his five-year-old son
will a jury believe his confession was
coerced
[Music]
plus accused murderer and real estate
air robert durst
hospitalized during his trial we cannot
proceed without him being here
long crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
27 years ago this weekend tragedy struck
leading to one of the most sensational
criminal trials
the world has ever seen angel lady has
more on the o.j simpson case
brian this case set off an absolute
frenzy to this day there are people who
support
o.j simpson's claims that he is innocent
one of his former lawyers is one of them
but there are others who say that o.j
simpson is a murderer
june 12 1994 nicole brown simpson and
ron goldman were found in a bloody crime
scene in front of her condo
after a nine-month trial a jury found
o.j simpson
not guilty it is clear that
o.j simpson in my mind got away with
murder
and that he was eventually
held to account to some degree in the
civil trial
that occurred months later in santa
monica
law and crime network founder dan abrams
covered the o.j
simpson trial the defense did a very
good job of sort of
creating all these possible
theory mark furman planted the glove
and planted the evidence one member of
the simpson defense team who stood by
o.j simpson's claims of innocence
literally to his dying day was f lee
bailey
the first thing you have to show is
opportunity
if the defendant had no opportunity to
commit the crime
case over right then in the simpson case
there was no opportunity bailly wrote
about his part in the case and his
steadfast belief in simpson's innocence
in the truth
about the o.j simpson trial by the
architect of the defense
jenny sisson helped bailly write the
book what's
startling is the lack
of blood evidence that was
linked to oj i mean really it was such a
bloody scene
how could there be so little blood at
his residence
in other places questioning blood
evidence was the central part of the
defense
the blood and simpsons ford bronco the
blood at the crime scene and the bloody
glove
the defense suggested detective mark
furman planted the bloody glove on
simpson's property
while the state argued it wasn't planted
and that simpson owned the shoes that
left footprints at the crime scene
pat mckenna was one of simpson's
investigators
it really was a travesty
it exposed lapd for and there was plenty
of good cops trust me i know
i met some good people
they weren't all bad but there was a few
people in there
that said it's when it all costs the
families of nicole brown simpson
and ron goldman were devastated by the
jury's verdict in the criminal case
months later they received some measure
of justice when a civil jury found
simpson responsible for their murders
the picture of o.j simpson wearing
the bruno molly shoes from a newsletter
from nine months before the murder
is the final piece that should convince
anyone
who had any questions about o.j
simpson's guilt
now the jury in the civil case awarded
the families of ron goldman and nicole
brown simpson
33.5 million dollars but o.j simpson has
never paid that judgment ron goldman
actually obtained the rights to a book
that o.j simpson wrote back in 2006
called
if i did it and he then published that
book and collected the proceeds from it
many believe that book was essentially
simpson's confession
brian thanks ange joining us today is a
judge of the texas
292nd district the honourable judge
brandon birmingham
and terry austin your honor skilled
attorneys representing a guilty man
an innocent man vindicated or something
different altogether
where do you think the case of o.j
simpson lies
i think it's the uh the best example we
have in our jurisprudence between
somebody who was innocent versus
somebody who
i think that the the jurors were not
convinced that he was guilty
but i agree with mr abrams and a whole
lot of other folks that o.j got away
with murder that day
but it just wasn't proven beyond a
reasonable doubt the defense did a good
job of poking holes in that case and
that's the verdict yeah i always tell
people there's never a box on a verdict
sign that says innocent it's either
guilty or not guilty
so it's very hard to prove innocence
there so i agree with you there terry
you've had a belief since the verdict of
o.j
simpson has anything from oj's lawyers
made you think differently
not at all brian and this is such a
partisan issue i think people either
believe
he's guilty or he's not guilty and any
evidence to the contrary doesn't really
change anyone's mind
i think it was overwhelming i think he
had a motive he had an opportunity and i
think he had the means
and there were no other viable suspects
and the thing that
really in my opinion makes him guilty is
the chase i think that that is
absolutely
something that makes it seem as though
he has consciousness
of guilt and he also you know threatened
suicide it's just no question in my mind
that there was enough to prove him
guilty but obviously the jury
did not think the same way yeah but as
danny abrams says those shoes and even
the book after the fact kind of leads
you to believe
he probably did it but again he's voted
not guilty and jeanette
the simpson case led to some changes
within the lapd right
yeah major changes brian there were
changes made to the crime lab and how
they collected evidence the feds
actually came in at one point that was
after
of course the rodney king case and did
an
overhaul of sorts there were changes
made to several protocols
and the da's office actually made
changes as well to the way they would
try these cases
the way they've presented things to the
grand jury so there were sweeping
changes that were made huge lessons
learned especially with the collection
of evidence
and the protocols for storing that
evidence absolutely it makes sense
you've got to prosecute a little bit
better if you don't want
things like this o.j simpson getting off
his murder as many people believe
still ahead on law and crime daily
robert durst's first trial
may be on pause while he's in the
hospital but that won't stop attorneys
from arguing about the so-called jinx
but first the trial of the tennessee
father who confessed to murdering his
five-year-old son
then recanted closing arguments next
[Music]
welcome back a jury is now deliberating
the fate of a tennessee man accused of
killing
his five-year-old autistic son
joseph ray daniels is on trial for
allegations he murdered joseph clyde
daniels
also known as baby joe the boy is last
seen on april 3
2018 and reported missing the next day
his body has never been found the
prosecution called roughly half of the
60 witnesses they expected to call
the defense called none alex the
defendant's now 11 year old stepson
took center stage in closing arguments
the prosecution pled with the jury to
believe the boy
who was just eight years old when his
little brother was murdered
you saw alex testify
he was eight years old when this
happened
and he said i didn't tell the truth
in the beginning because i was trying to
protect him
but that was a lie he said i'm here to
tell you the truth now
i'm here to tell you what happened and
here's what the defendant says
about alex
tell the truth
the defendant says alex is a good boy he
doesn't lie
i know they interviewed him i'm pretty
sure he told him everything
the defense in turn wanted to present a
different argument
they now claim that the then
eight-year-old stepson caused baby joe's
death
it's whatever alex told them
agent boyd is threatening to investigate
alex
the next page page 135.
agent boyd i understand that what i
i want you i wish you would believe me
when i told you that no matter what you
tell me right now
you tell me the truth you'll walk out
that door
you're walking out of here okay i
promise i can promise you that no matter
what you say right now
you're walking out that door
he's asking him to say alex did it
back with us is judge birmingham and
co-host terry austin
terry what do you make of the
prosecution building their case
on the words of a now 11 year old
stepbrother was
that testimony powerful oh brian it was
very powerful there's no question that
alex loved his little brother and i
think there was even some survivor's
guilt there
and you know the prosecution relied on
that testimony
and they also relied on the testimony of
the speech therapist
the therapist was amazing she said that
joe clyde was a loving little boy
he loved his apples and the prosecution
relied on that the prosecution actually
opened up with that and closed with that
talking about the fact that
this little boy had a simple little
desire to have
apples and the last thing that the
prosecution said
in closing was i won't ever see an apple
again without thinking about baby joe
clyde
and frankly brian i won't ever look at
an apple the same
either definitely powerful arguments to
leave the jury with as they go into
deliberating
uh judge birmingham the defense out of
nowhere is kind of leaving this little
nugget
that the then eight-year-old stepbrother
um
maybe did this crime in some way shape
or form
what did you make of that a great last
minute move or a misstep by the defense
well certainly something inconsistent
with the idea that he just totally
made up a confession uh and that had
nothing to do with the killing of
of baby joe uh if if you're going to say
that this
the eight-year-old brother was involved
in somehow and opening the trunk and
doing that well that implies that the
baby was killed at the house and then
you've got to rectify that somehow with
this confession you're saying is
falsified and
when you put all of these different
pieces together it is a tough road to
hold
for the defense in this case absolutely
the jury is still continuing to
deliberate
listening to all of the testimony if you
recall what do you think about this not
putting on a defense terry
no witness or anything from the defense
what'd you think of that well you know
it would've been hard to put on the
defendant himself i mean i suppose they
could have put on a psychologist
but i think at the end of the day if i
had been that defense i probably
wouldn't put anything on either
yeah i would have guessed maybe a false
confessions expert if that was
what they were going with talking about
recanting and showing the elements of
that to a jury but that's just this
public defenders from brooklyn opinion
we'll see how this case goes out of
tennessee coming up on law and crime
daily
all is fair in love and drug cartels why
one drug kingpin's wife is going to the
big house
plus we ask the experts about the
compelling testimony
of an 11 year old boy against his
stepfather accused of killing his son
more on the murder of joseph clyde
daniels next
we're back jurors are continuing to
deliberate in the tennessee trial
of a father accused of killing his
five-year-old autistic son
terry austin spoke with a clinical
psychologist who discussed one of the
state's key witnesses
brian alex was just eight years old when
his brother went missing
he's 11 now and was emotional on the
stand
dr catherine coleman says kids in
general know the difference between
the truth and a lie
as adults we're abstract we can think
about consequences but kids are very
much
black and white right and wrong and so
kids
by and large understand the difference
between
lying and truth telling and for them
lying is bad and telling the truth is a
good thing
i saw them laying on the ground who was
laying on the ground
joe clyde yes and what was the defendant
doing
he he was about to pick him up and carry
him out the door
he said and dad here tell me if i didn't
help so back at the time
when he was eight he didn't tell
investigators anything but now he's 11
and he is testifying that his stepfather
beat his baby brother what do you think
about those
inconsistencies so i think you know at
the time
when he initially didn't provide any
information about what he saw or
or didn't say anything that was
incriminating about his stepfather
there was that threat of violence if he
spoke out and so that could influence
and make him more suggestible in what
he's telling investigators
[Music]
could he be feeling some guilt because
he was the one
who actually informed the stepdad that
his little brother had you know urinated
on the floor
and it did seem as though he felt a
little guilt that's when he
started to get very emotional yes
in any situation like this where there's
some type of trauma sometimes there is
this survivor's guilt
you know why then why not me was i the
person that caused this
when he refers to his stepfather in the
courtroom as that man and him
what that shows me though is that he's
really distanced himself from the
situation and
that he may have kind of a bigger grasp
on the fact that that man
you know allegedly is bad um and so he's
able to separate that that's a bad man
that did a bad thing
and that i necessarily didn't do
anything wrong
do you recall telling a different story
no i actually do but
it was faith it was a false story how do
you think the jury
is going to respond to a child
on the stand he's only 11 years old and
he's doing a great job testifying
what is a jury thinking about anybody
our hearts just always bleed for
children and so when you see a child
providing testimony especially when they
become emotional
right our emotional side is going to
want to reach out to that kid
and so i think that that this is
probably very compelling
evidence for the jury because we're
human and we also tie emotions
to to content and memories too this is
definitely going to stick out to them
great interview when we come back robert
durst is in the hospital
could the millionaire real estate heirs
trial be delayed again
we discuss next
welcome back the wife of the infamous
drug kingpin joaquin el chapo guzman
is pleading guilty to helping run her
husband's drug trafficking empire
emma cornel alspero was arrested earlier
this year in a virginia airport
on thursday she admitted in court to
three charges against her
conspiring to distribute illegal drugs
laundering money
and engaging in foreign narcotics
trafficking she's also accused of
helping guzman escape from a mexican
prison
and evade capture cornell was born in
california and is a dual citizen
of the u.s and mexico guzman is
currently in federal custody
serving a life sentence testimony in the
trial of the millionaire real estate
area is set to resume on monday
after robert durst was hospitalized
during his trial
robert durst is accused of murdering his
best friend susan berman in december
2000 to allegedly
stop her from going to authorities about
information about his missing wife
kathy his defense says the 78 year old
is very sick
suffers from bladder cancer malnutrition
and chronic kidney disease
but prosecutor john lewin says duress
has been hurt on jail calls
saying he would fake dementia and secure
a mistrial due to covid
the judge says durst wouldn't have been
taken to the hospital without a
legitimate question to his health
he was down he was he was not in his
chair so
he's uh he's uh so he needed to be seen
and uh is it false is it fake they do a
good job
at that jail that's all i mean he'll be
brought to court if he's if he's good
for court
in the doctor's opinion at the jail and
he will not be brought to court if he's
too ill for court
and i trust that judgment also
testimony ended with one of the
defendant's friends on the stand as a
hostile witness
where he was asked about speaking with
durst in jail after the jury left
the defense moved for a mistrial
i i didn't really want to talk about
what he was here for
and i i thought i'd be
nice to have discussions about some
pleasant things also his lawyers told
you not to talk to bob about anything
related to the case correct
yes they said it it's not good to talk
because
everything's objections yeah if mr
lewin's purpose is to undermine the
credibility of this witness
i think that one could say that he's had
plenty of ammunition
to have to comment on mr durst's right
to remain silent
is it is more prejudicial than probative
it is
that is a good argument that's a better
word your honor i'm not going to comment
at all this has nothing to do with mr
durst's right to remain silent
it is not mr durst who's saying things
is mr oliver right so here's the thing
i'm not i'm i don't think there's a
sixth amendment or fifth amendment
problem here but i do think this is more
prejudicial than probative so i did
strike the answer
okay the jury to disregard it i'm
instructing you not to ask
questions of that nature you you have
destroyed the credibility of this
witness already
judge birmingham help me out here we've
seen a lot of courtroom drama in
in the durst case with the judge letting
the lawyers get away with
a lot what do you make of the sparks
flying in this trial
the lawyers and they're they're fighting
amongst
each other to to devour the entire uh
trial you want the trial to be about the
facts and this well-regulated search for
the truth i mean
you know and i was commenting we were
talking a little bit over break this
reminds me
when the lawyers get too much of the
jack ruby trial you know there's a good
book out about that right now called
kennedy's avenger but
uh you know that that that trial is uh
was known more for
the the sparks that flew among the
lawyers and it was what actually
happened in the case
on the other hand on the other side of
the equation a well-regulated trial
might be a good example might be the
timothy mcveigh trial all the lawyers
talked about how judge mage
ran a very fair courtroom ran things
made decisions
made them concisely and didn't let the
lawyers sort of run wild and
you want to be somewhere in between
those i think that's the goal anyway
yeah running wild is definitely
something that seems to be
a common thread here in the robert durst
trial terry
talk to us about the prosecution having
a hostile witness on the stand
and is it worth having a witness testify
when the defendant was literally
cheering on his boy oliver
well you know oliver definitely was a
hostile witness and lewin asked for him
to be declared
such in the very beginning of his
testimony and that way he could ask
leading questions he could suggest the
answer and i think that that worked but
i think oliver was a bit biased here and
the jury will pick up on that
absolutely judge terry thank you very
much and thank you for joining us here
on longer news we'll see you next time
with justice in america
[Music]
you